ce à quoi bon soir là bas bonsoir mon
sport et encore une nouvelle coque ou
toujours pas toujours par nous ont pas
vraiment dire toujours pas aller
j'arrive déjà mais alors ce sont dans
les lauriers cyril hanouna qui prouve
encore une fois qu'il est aussi bon en
pronostics que des mécanismes et en
coiffure le meilleur sosie de michael
jackson de l'univers doc gynéco au
sommet de sa forme et surtout pour finir
attention je vais vous annoncer enfin ce
soir qui le délire de cyril hanouna
je cours bien vous allez voir je suis
toute la france n'avait vous allez voir
alors je dis vous avez décidé de voir la
série lequel de vos chroniqueurs mais le
plus gros qi oui et comme c'est un
compétiteur vous adorez faire des
pronostics oui vous allez donc annoncé
qui selon vous allez avoir le plus beau
le plus gros que lui
je vous remets le laurier du super
animateur super chanteur super danseurs
mais très mauvais pronostiqueur
comment 150 animateurs préférés vous
aviez trois favoris il soit très bien
sûr dans le test du qi oui je mise
beaucoup sur vous ben très bien je vous
le dis je me sur jean michel maire non
non et ou paca maker benjamin résultats
qui l'emportent et daniel mans
encore une fois vous vous êtes trompé
alors je dis encore pourquoi parce que
souvenez vous de votre pronostic pour
destination eurovision je pense que sur
france 2 ils vont faire un carton samedi
soir ça pas hyper bien marché on va pas
se mentir à ses habitants un échec cette
histoire d'eurovision je vais vous
pronostiqu l'eau pour la cérémonie des
césar où c'est ce qui va faire un carton
d'audience
moi je perds c'est malheureusement le
pire score des césar depuis la création
de la cérémonie et monastique le bureau
c'est celui pour l'élection de miss
france 2010 9 miss rhône alpes
ah oui je le sens bien miss tahiti c'est
pas mon truc pas mon truc grave pour
être bon partout alors je rappelle que
le gain pour le vainqueur du concours du
cui était un prime time sur s'est vite
mais franchement c'est super preuve que
vous aviez oublié un détail que daniel
moreau pouvait remporter le test et d'en
gagner en prime alors je vous remets le
laurier de l'animateur qui devient
subitement sourd quand on lui pose une
question qui ne la rend pas du coup on
peut gagner un prime time le meilleur
gagnera c'est fait et quand on vous
rappelle que daniela a gagné un prime
voilà votre réponse et vous avez gagné
bravo vous à la gagnante reine du coup
j'avais gagné alors
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors jeudi soir et balances ton post
c'était le retour de cyril hanouna
éditorialistes celui qui peut aussi bien
parler de la hausse du dow jones que la
nouvelle loi pinel 2019
évidemment alors vous savez bien sûr
parler de michael jackson et des
accusations du documentaire qui sera
diffusé jeudi
je crois sur m6 oui alors forcément vous
avez invité un sosie du roi de la pop
sur le plateau michael jackson ses
surnoms l'artiste qui a le plus de sosie
parfait dans le monde mais vraiment le
plus et comme d'habitude nos équipes ont
réalisé une prouesse avec le choix du
sosie je remets à valence est en poste
lors de l'émission qu'un mythe est le
sosie dont le seul point commun avec
michael jackson
c'est les lunettes alors maintenant
public on n'est pas forcément convaincu
par la ressemblance royal jeune fille
derrière eux leur acheter bon ben vous
êtes chorégraphe et sosie de michael
jackson merci sosie de michael jackson
alors en fait c'est gilles verdez avec
une perruque un condensé effectivement
comme michael jackson mais michael
jackson maintenant je pense
[Applaudissements]
il était très bon ils n'étaient pas
pendant que toi
ah ouais le moonwalk ont été changés
ouais parce que d'abord franchement je
l'adoré alors j'ai envie qu'on fasse un
petit jeu rapide musique de suspense
question quand c'est terminé
balances ton post jeudi soir à 1h03 à
1h33 au vendredi à 18h30 croire à votre
avis la réponse bertrand
n'ai-je pas à 1h03 dont on a terminé
tout même une croix très tôt très tôt
soit une heure trop alors alors vous
après 6 heures d'antenne vous êtes en
pleine forme vous pourriez largement
enchaîné sans problème avec la
présentation de gym direct sauf l'udc
pour le public et vos équipes en régie
c'est plus dur c'est très dur de rester
éveillé sitar notamment pour l'un des
spectateurs les plus fidèles de
l'émission je sais pas s'il est là ce
soir c'est vous n'en seriez pas là ce
n'est pas là ce soir alors je remets
danse donc ma balance ton poste lors de
l'émission qu'on adore mais qui passe
beaucoup trop tard on a l'habitude de
voir venance en pleine forme à 19h dans
tpm fin mai à 23h30 il est beaucoup plus
calme
en régie le dj s'est une nouvelle fois
endormi on comprend mieux pourquoi
l'émission va n'y a pas de musique
correct c'est vrai avec soin la loi et à
minuit et demi on a complètement perdu
venance regardez-moi ça y est sony et la
pluie regarder à lui ya lui alors est-ce
que je parlais de doc gynéco vous savez
que j'ai une bien sûr pour doc gynéco
qui est avec nous tous les sens on
touche pas à mon poste et sa prestation
dans le problème sur le cui a été
inoubliable
alors jeudi le débat n'était pas prévu
dans valence compost mais vous avez la
surprise s'irrite de voir arriver le
rappeur au moment où vous allez rendre
l'antenne à la fin de l'émission il
voulait faire un texte pour lancer qui
est meilleur que lui alors que
l'émission était fini depuis 4h sert à
ça c'était magnifique
je remets donc à l'animal le laurier de
l'animateur qui adore doc gynéco mais
qui n'a plus aucune patience quand
public aux heures du matin alors on me
prête des locaux apprend qu'il est pas
privé de relance au poste
regardez la détresse incroyable dans ses
yeux aux dites vous faites pas btp en
fait c'était pas prévu à reims
[Musique]
j'ai donc de venir vous fait faire une
visite surprise en fin d'émission le
problème c'est que cyril détester
surprise doc gynéco qu'est ce que vous
voulez donc j'étais en train d'écrire
attention ça va partir d'un donneur
ouais mon ego est terminée puis ashley
qui va nous faire une petite
démonstration
soyez prêt attachez vos ceintures on va
décoller mais l'émission algérie a
décollé du tout va on va atterrir coup
bah oui tu crois que tu es le début de
l'émission
mais non mais j'étais en train d'écrire
vous allez trop loin c'est la feuille de
menthe
c'est extraordinaire au statut on va
décoller la plus grande force c'est
d'être ensemble paris personne ne peut
nous attaquer un groupe uni avoir 200
accord de cui donné cette image à l
avance telle autre émission d'oc
aujourd'hui n'a pas fait son tag deux
plans il est temps vous présenter celle
qui est le délire de série là les
doudous sorte et ça en fait parce que ça
se voit je me sens vous allez voir vous
la connaissez tous la semaine dernière
géraldine vous demandez qui est l auteur
du livre féerie pour une autre fois
c'est louis ferdinand céline est
évidemment le fait que vous savez c'est
facile pour vous et au moment où vous
allez répondre à cette question très
facile pour vous vous avez dû sortir en
urgence du plateau pour sauver la vie de
trois nageurs oui qui se noyait dans un
pédiluve oui c'est vrai que c'est pas
facile
parmi les nageurs y avait louis et le
ferdinand mais pour vous il y avait
surtout céline une jeune fille en
maillot de bain et je pense avoir enfin
trouvé le délire de l'animal je remets à
cyril hanouna le lorie de l'animateur
qui n'arrive pas à cacher qu'il est en
train de mater non avec les mecs vous
êtes rapide vous les sortez de l'eau de
manière professionnelle voilà quand vous
apercevez céline 5
en direct
quel coup de foudre
et
hélas ces costumes aux yeux étaient
attirés par céline et ce qui est
magnifique
si vous n'êtes pas le seul regarder le
vigile a très envie de protéger ces
innocents du seul festival de petits
cousins et regarder les coups d'oeil un
point haut en bas la petite boucle
athlètes
on avait un petit problème failli se
noyer
alors écoutez et ben j'arrive mais ça va
tout va mieux
avant de repartir une dernière fois
clamé vous regardez ici les fans mais je
suis professionnel et je regardais
gemmois sauver c'est nîmes que les deux
à fond je suis désolé mais non mais je
suis toute la france est-ce que témoin
vous voyez le mal à en parler les images
pas vouloir détourner l' on le voit pas
besoin de vos commentaires
vérifiez les pulsations graphie à sordo
il des risques des deux garçons mais
manifestement vous gardé le meilleur
pour la fin
j'ai une surprise
j'ai une surprise pour vous bah j'ai
commencé à courir comment à comprendre
la surprise son ancien compagnon parce
que vous vous derrière journal de merde
le délire de cyril elle est proche de
nous bah oui balle est là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça va
largo est là pour voilà qui perso à l'
hyper super chaud alors allez vous
changer céline mercy était prévu accents
très bon manos dans l'oise hauteur et
c'est alors franchement vous tromper
complètement ça alors j'aime beaucoup la
personne humaine mouche la codi mais
voilà mais je n'ai pas du tout et dont
on va la voir renoncer va la voir et
lire après ouais on va la voir revenir
après et on va voir je vous dirais
personnellement voilà cicero c'est beau
et je vous rappelle bien entendu comme
l'ensemble de la france le sait je n'ai
pas de zone des zizis 6 ou le séminaire
sur les gars je vous retient à vous et
vous des cathares conseil c'est
n'importe quoi n'importe quoi